i
la extrema derecha está arrasando en
toda europa países como francia holanda
o austria tienen partidos xenófobos con
posibilidades reales de llegar al
gobierno sin embargo españa vive ajena a
esta tendencia y la pregunta es porque
hoy en visual político te lo vamos a
contar y lo vamos a hacer de la mano de
víctor fernández doctorando en ciencia
política en la universidad de estocolmo
y nuevo colaborador de este canal
a raíz de las últimas elecciones en
austria hace un mes podríamos ver de
nuevo a los titulares como la extrema
derecha está avanzando a europa el
candidato verde ganó al candidato del pp
austriaco hoffer por apenas unos miles
de votos y gracias al que captó el voto
de todos los partidos que se habían
quedado a las puertas de la ciudad donde
la extrema derecha europea celebra
unánime el triunfo del fp o en austria
porque está definido tanto la extrema
derecha en europa bueno podemos ver unas
ciertas similitudes comunes entre todos
los partidos extrema derecha alrededor
de europa si bien es cierto que no
podemos comparar a unos con otros por
ejemplo este amanecer dorado es
imposible compararlo con por ejemplo
pero uso mal hay siete en finlandia o el
propio fp o en austria sin embargo como
he dicho hay unas ciertas similitudes
comunes que podemos analizar la primera
es el nacionalismo también hay un cierto
antiliberalismo y una tendencia
estatalizar los medios de producción
estatalizar la banca extractar las
energías cera etcétera
el 19 de septiembre puedes elegir entre
frenar la inmigración o frenar las
pensiones vota a los demócratas de
suecia seguridad y tradición también
podemos ver un intento de control cada
vez más amplio sobre las fronteras y
sobre la inmigración y todos estos
batidos están creciendo por el miedo a
la población que presentan personas de
otras culturas que hay ciertos problemas
que los partidos funcionales no han
sabido resolver o que no han sabido
tratar puesto que llevarlos al debate
público quizá estaba mal visto
y en españa qué pasa no hay partidos de
extrema derecha
si hay pero es totalmente irrelevante en
el debate político tenemos al mismo tres
falanges tenemos dos plataformas per
catalunya tenemos una españa en marcha
que es una coalición de varias
formaciones pero realmente ninguna en
ningún momento entra el debate público
consigue ningún tipo de apoyo mediático
ni relevante ningún sentido de ello que
sacrificó su vida por la patria españa
tanto como portugal son los casos
especiales en europa son los dos países
donde digamos que la extrema derecha
menos ha cuajado y quizá en españa el
caso españa es por su anclaje en el
franquismo y su alcance las antiguas
estructuras que sustentan el franquismo
su época ambas una contraloría de
católicos contra francos contra la
reconquista contra la iglesia católica
vemos como en el año 79 sí que un
diputado de extrema derecha a blas píñar
en este caso consiguió un escaño por
madrid en las cortes generales pero esto
no se volvía a repetir los mensajes que
ha transmitido la extrema derecha en
españa se han quedado muy anticuados es
una extrema derecha que no ha renunciado
en ningún momento al franquismo una
renuncia ni un momento incluso partes
que han sido más identificadas con el
fascismo con el nacionalsocialismo
tampoco han renunciado a los crímenes
fascistas los crímenes sanciona
socialistas como pueden
y digamos todos los puntos arriba españa
a españa y es una derecha que se
mantiene muy reaccionaria en unas
posiciones que no atraen a la gran masa
la población
si lanzáramos tenemos vendió
realmente se ha modernizado a la derecha
europea extrema derecha europeos y que
se ha habido un reciclaje completo de
esos partidos sí que es verdad que
algunos como amanecer o lado como el npd
en alemania que está mismo en proceso de
ilegalización nunca en un momento han
reformado su mensaje y esto le ha valido
desaprobación de todos y todo de la
sociedad y de hecho solamente en grecia
han crecido por la grave crisis
económica está subiendo país que es la
más grave desde la segunda guerra
mundial sin embargo en los demás países
de europa este proceso ha sido ha sido
apabullante y consideró que europa ha
cometido un error en el pasado debería
haber establecido relaciones de
cooperación de desarrollo económico con
áfrica porque creo que es una de las
maneras de fijar a las poblaciones en su
país de origen y sacó los partidos de
extrema derecha en ningún momento apoya
en el holocausto nazi de hecho condenan
el genocidio condena en el nazismo
condenar el fascismo condenan incluso
que ese deporte de forma sistemática a
todos los inmigrantes es un discurso
completamente renovado y que puedo
atraer a gran parte la sociedad que
ahora mismo se siente desarraigada de
por los partidos tradicionales eso es lo
que repite la clase política le dice
muchas cosas
día a día
y cuáles son los motivos por los que no
surgen partidos de extrema derecha al
estilo europeo en españa bueno pues hay
varios tenemos el catolicismo que aunque
no lo creamos es muy importante tenemos
la procedencia y la emigración tenemos
el propio proceso centralizador de
españa' de formación como nación tenemos
las luchas por el poder y tenemos la ley
electoral son cinco factores muy muy
importantes para conocer porque la
extrema derecha no ha triunfado en
españa' número uno el sistema electoral
el primer factor en este caso sería el
electoral en las elecciones de 1939 blas
píñar consigue un diputado pero consigue
300.000 votos esta extrema derecha
tardofranquista quizás si en una vez con
electoral más proporcional hubiese
obtenido más escaños sin embargo entre
está este problema coral electoral y
luego el golpe de estado fracasado del
año 81 hicieron que la población se
sintiera completamente realizada y
completamente en contra de una extrema
derecha que podría volver que nos podría
hacer volver a los tiempos de escaños
número 2 la inmigración la admiración es
muy importante en españa puesto que en
españa a diferencia de los otros países
de europa tiene una inmigración
proveniente de hispanoamérica con una
misma lengua con la misma cultura con
una misma religión y esto es muy
importante puesto que incluso los
sectores más reaccionarios de nuestra
sociedad están a favor de este tipo de
inmigración puesto que al ser más
religiosos hace que muchos crean que
puede ser la salvación digamos del
catolicismo la vuelta de los valores
tradicionales a la de españa actual
número 3 el catolicismo y hablando del
catolicismo la mayoría de los países de
europa la unión religión y extrema
derecha actualmente es muy escasa creo
que prohibir el aborto no es un buen
método sin embargo en españa es a donde
siempre por la trizadura de francos en
este aspecto en la españa de la
transición sí que hubo una alianza entre
los partidos digamos más de extrema
derecha europea y los partidos tras dos
artistas o partidos católicos
propiamente dicho camaradas o la 'españa
en marcha con la falange con alianza
nacional con democracia nacional con el
nudo fácil de español con el movimiento
católico español sin embargo actualmente
esto es imposible dado que un partido de
extrema derecha europea aunque no esté
reciclado como estos nunca a aceptar
ningún tipo de inmigración te embargo un
partido católico sí que te va a aceptar
una inmigración culturalmente igual como
por ejemplo puede ser la
hispanoamericana como os hemos hablado
antes por tanto este tipo de división es
hace que es imposible una conjunción
entre ambos tipos de partido al ser en
el fondo tenía una ideología bastante
diferente
número 4 las divisiones internas es
importante hablar de que en españa
también la extrema derecha siempre ha
estado muy atomizada ahora mismo existen
tres tipos de falanges diferentes unas
enfrentadas con otras dos tipos de
plataformas de cataluña y todos estos
procesos son tan interesantes como
caóticos para los propios partidos
porque son unas luchas de poder por
partidos minúsculos tremenda algo que en
otros partidos con otros y en otros
países en otros países no existe en
francia en alemania en hungría tenemos
partidos fuertes que tendrán su lucha de
poder pero ni un momento hacen dividir
al partido no vengáis a francia de
verdad si no va a gustar está todo ya
lloviendo hace una humedad malísima que
eso para el pelo africano es fatal ya lo
sabéis vosotros un asunto que se ha
prestado poca atención en la prensa
española y en general incluso en la
europea es en los postulados económicos
de estos partidos
número 5 la economía
los económicos anti liberales han sido
adoptados por los partidos tema
izquierdas pero en ningún momento han
sido todos por la extrema derecha cosa
que en finlandia en suecia en francia sí
que se han usado muchísimo el lema
principal de marie le pen uno de los
temas principales es acabemos con los
recortes acabemos con el neoliberalismo
salgamos del euro la ultraderecha es la
que está a la derecha de la derecha la
que considera que hay que tener todavía
más ultraliberalismo casi en el límite
de la ley de la selva' en finlandia el
partido del de los verdaderos
finlandeses está bajando las encuestas
no porque de repente la población
finlandesa esté a favor de refugiados
sino porque había defendido una salida
del euro es un partido final encendido
un fin de los recortes y al final acabó
pactando con un partido liberal y con un
partido de centro agrario que lo que han
hecho ha sido seguir con esos recortes y
han tenido que trabajar
y el apoyo al partido de los finlandeses
cae por debajo del 10% y vosotros qué
crees existen más factores que impidan
la entrada de partidos políticos de
extrema derecha en el parlamento creéis
que próximamente a medio plazo podría
aparecer algún partido nuevo de extrema
derecha esperaba nuestros comentarios
para abrir debate y bueno muchas gracias
y hasta la próxima